regardez qu'est la voulais juste péché
vous dire que nahla va bien je vous
avais promis que je vous l'amènerai
aujourd'hui match sourit d'amour je
laime trop fabien soul et il arrive à
istanbul en 2017 pour y subir une
opération chirurgicale on va parler des
implants capillaires c'est ça une
opération c'est juste des implants
capillaires pendant son séjour il va
commander et se faire livrer du gbl
alors vous demandez ce que c'est que gbl
le gbl c'est une drogue de synthèse
c'est ça qui est un excitant sexuelle à
la base
oui c'est un détergent pour les jantes
de voiture d'accord donc quand vous
l'acheter quand vous le commandez en
ligne vous le corps des sous cette forme
l'accord à son nom à son hôtel
là où il réside donc il a vraiment le
sentiment qu'il n'y a aucun problème a
commandé ce produit en turquie
d'autant plus que le site prévoir sur le
côté droit
une liste des pays dans lequel le
produit est interdite et la turquie ne
figure pas que pour cause
le produit n'a été classifié comme
stupéfiant que quelques mois auparavant
par décret et ça a échappé à la
vigilance du site internet david alors
dit quand je regarde mon acte de
condamnations qui dit libération le 23
mai 2034
j'ai le coeur qui bat plein pot je ne
tiendrais pas jusque là je le sais je le
son je n'en n'aurai pas la force
tu sais ici il n'y a pas de présomption
d'innocence comme il y en europe et aux
états unis
c'est un système qui condamne quelles
que soient les circonstances cette peine
de 20 ans est tellement inconcevable
dans une de ses lettres si fabien
explique à quel point il n'est pas fait
pour ce monde d'horreur et de violences
dans cette prison personne ne peut
imaginer des horreurs auxquelles j'ai
assisté ce n'est juste aucun voilà par
consommables ici que ce sont tous des
récidivistes ils ont l'habitude des
prisons les moi non je ne sais pas je ne
sais même pas me défendre moi si j'ai un
client qui est pas content du travail
que je fais sort le dossier voilà ce que
j'ai fait et nous on est client du quai
d'orsay je suis désolé mais il travaille
pour nous donc à un moment donné il faut
qu'ils nous apportent des résultats
on va essayer de dessiner notre petit
niveau de faire bouger les choses
peut-être au niveau de l'ambassade de
turquie peut être au niveau
je pense que c'est la meilleure personne
appelée je pense que c'est exactement
[Musique]
passé
ouais
alors là
en effet un des co détenus a exercé
différentes formes de violence contre
lui ce qui est inacceptable et ce dont
on peut se féliciter c'est que les
responsables des prisons ont pris les
mesures pour le mettre en sécurité
donc ça c'est une première chose et les
entreprises ont pour le sonder nicky et
mme voilà c'est incompréhensible alors
la longueur de la peine
pour mieux la comprendre il faut
imaginer la carte d'europe et la carte
où se trouve la turquie la turquie étant
géographiquement sur les voies de trafic
de stupéfiants malheureusement pour
entre guillemets protéger l'europe
occidentale nous sommes obligés d'avoir
des lois très dur pour dissuader les
trafiquants de drogue
alors tous vos efforts l'intérêt que
vous avez porté à cette question va
permettre aux administrations de traiter
cela le plus rapidement possible ensuite
si on essaie de pousser la chose jusqu'à
demander une intervention politique
à mon sens très sincèrement ça ne peut
être que contre productif
je sais bon foot franchement les
conneries un moment donné on essaye de
sauver un pays on essaie de sauver
l'europe mais à un moment donné il faut
être légaliste et jour loin jean et il
faut écouter et respecter les lois et
les règles eh ben le reste ce sont les
gens
on a réclamé un arrêt non mais ça oui
c'est mieux on prenait la parole quand
je vous la donne ne voulait pas d'autres
je me tais l'homme et du oui au oui avec
jaguar hibou qui lui fait prendre
attendait cela veut il dire on va faire
ça avec eux c'est parce que vous croyez
quoi la bodega de ces bons ne parvient
pas c'est pourquoi brevets si demont là
et pas de vente de chambrer ses saisons
des cités on passe son temps à hurler
il fait si tout le monde alors c'est toi
c'est bon maintenant j'offre mon nom
mais c'est vrai donc moi je moi je vous
rejoins tous le poids mais vous savez on
a tous un peu raison mais le bateau sur
epte fabrice di vizio et le dossier ne
pouvait pas frapper comme ça sur la
vitrine riposte je t'ai jamais mais
alors non militaire voilà non mais on
reste tranquille s'il vous plaît voilà
gentiment parce qu'on l'a invité eh bien
[Musique]
partout
il est bien c'est danone c'est un grand
groupe
ils savent très bien ce qu'ils font it
up sur les musulmans et il voit que ça
suscite une polémique donc il s'excuse y
sont obligé de s'excuser mais c'est
scandaleux de faire ça c'est pas du tout
islamistes alors géraldine maillet et
gilles verdez pardon mais je trouve que
tu es fou furieux
ça a été et est vraiment un danger
public c'est bien mais ça fait une
polémique n'a pas fini de la génération
jean vidéo foncé des indignés qui tombe
dans le sort de tourbillon comme ça
indique si mr c'est dramatique d'abord
il se comporte en idiot utile de
l'islamisme
non mais non mais non j'ai pas mon nom
et la balance avec evian fait tous les
jours des tweets choix même pas si je
finis verdez aggrave le sentiment de
persécution des musulmans pour un motif
en plus imaginaires c'est déjà assez
tendue je vous ai senti je vous ai
sentis énervé hier qu'est ce qui vous a
énervé en fait pourquoi qui c'est
marrant de ce qu'est ce qui est marrant
c'est devenir penser que ce qui pose
problème c'est que benjamin castaldi
exprimer une colère en tapant sur la
vitre c'est marrant de penser que ce
soit ça qui m'est fait par thor qu'est
ce qui vous a fait partir c'est ce qu'il
a dit et s'il a dit il a dit
qu'effectivement concrètement pour
passer la séquence il a dit quoi il a
dit qu'en fait moi qui disais qu'il ne
se passait rien que rien n'était grave
qu'est ce qui lui permet de dire ça donc
c'est bon alors ce dîner des
intellectuels qu'il faut que monsieur
c'est bon non j'étais pas l'excusé
donnée
excusez moi mais mes répliques vous êtes
il est insuffisant et insupportable
titre étant cieux suffisant et un
supporter est quand même allé ce message
intéressant ça c'est intéressant que je
suis prétentieux monsieur je ne sais pas
si je suis prête à l'avancé baba
regardez-vous d'être peut-être un
peut-être j'ai pas la prétention de ne
pas l'être mais peut-être effectivement
que j'ai une qualité monsieur par
rapport à vous je sais de quoi je parle
oui mon ami génial bravo monsieur allez
on appelait on est ronde
prenant la place de génial
je me devais gérer un bravo le
gouvernement a beau mais c'est bon c'est
moi aussi j'étais triste tout ça vous
amuse mais ce que pour donner pour sa
défense avaient surnommé o c est ce que
vous vous rendez compte monsieur que de
l'image que vous renvoyez aux français
ici qu'il images auront pensé exactement
quelqu'un il m'a joué mais si je vous
parle de régime des français au moins
gilbert glissement on peut débattre et
discuter mais je suis un tremblement de
vous merci rigole patrick s'est passé
[Applaudissements]
car la batterie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand j'étais enfin sur l'a5 j'avais un
contrat où j'avais la liberté éditoriale
de dire tout ce que je voulais sauce de
troubler l'ordre public c'est à dire
d'être à l'envers de la loi chose que
j'ai toujours respecté
mais depuis une dizaine d'années c'est
devenu complètement autre chose
c'est-à-dire que moi mes émissions il y
avait des gens qui étaient dans la salle
avait deux personnes dans la salle qui a
appelé tout de suite la chaîne a milan
il a dit ça il a dit ça et on me disait
coupez coupez coupez coupez la
souviendra d'auzan tu sortais d'une
braguette moi c'est pour ça que j'ai
plus du tout envie de revenir dans ce
milieu là parce que j'ai envie de finir
les actions
tout vous dire je vais tous vous sinon
je te plumerai que je vais tout vous
dire non alors aujourd'hui sachez le
tout est ouvert
maintenant et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs très possible qu'on va
sur ses 8 et où ces chats ne pensez pas
ce qui peut se passer voilà le sait le
même groupe
six mois ça dépend de la direction si la
direction de canal+ et la direction du
groupe me dit on a besoin de toi sur
canal+ bien entendu je ferai ce qu'ils
me disent qu'ils me diront de fer et la
gendarme la gendarme nous dit notre bout
de fille a été violée et c'est une
libération qu'ovide 19 donc déjà il
fallait encaissé le le fait que ma fille
bien chauffés violée le deuxième choc la
double peine
ça a été de savoir que cette personne a
été libéré sous caution
19 c'est à dire par rapport à la crise
sanitaire kobe de 19 essais au delà de
la colère ce faire il sait ça a été une
explosion interne en fait de tout notre
corps on s'est dit on on a on a on a
touché
on a touché notre propre chair on nous a
atteint on a sali ma fille on a pénétré
ma fille jette clair net précis par un
individu qui n'aurait jamais dû sortir
prison il a violenté son ex-compagne
compagne pardon mais 120 jours d'itt et
est donc un criminel
je passe mon or moi je suis très
sensible à ce que vous dites sur le fait
de ne pas minimiser
moi je me suis beaucoup battu contre
l'appellation frotteur en dix ans pas
d'effets routard ce sont des gens qui
commettent des agressions sexuelles
là l'idée c'était vraiment d'avoir un
truc impactants en politique il ya
beaucoup de sigles et je trouvais c'est
un petit clin d'oeil de dire moi je vais
fonder des qsr et les gens sont très
serrés nous avons qu'est ce que c'est
des cuvées serre et à des quartiers
s'envola en avant c'était jamais vous
c'était la vie en cité mais je vais vous
raconter une autre chose ce qui m'est
arrivé quand j'étais pour la mère de
famille j'étais trentenaire j'étais
suivie dans un train par un type qui
était bien sous tous rapports à la gare
montparnasse qui étaient en
costume-cravate avec une petite mallette
et un gobelet starbucks et la peur de ma
vie j'en suis sorti je sais pas comment
mais qui m'a tuer de façon très
agressive et donc je crois qu'avoir un
costard et habiter dans le xvième c'est
pas ça garantit pas que d'accord et j'ai
plein de cadeaux j'ai plein d'exemples
comme celui qui a débloqué 1 marlène
schiappa je vous le dis par les mecs en
costume avec je vous le dis je